ومن رافح معنا دكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه اهلا بك
معنا اذا كما كان يقول هشام مستشفيات خرجت
عن الخدمه واخرى تتعرض للقصف في اي ظروف
تعملون مع تواصل الغارات الاسرائيليه
العنيفه نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الواقع الصحي في قطاع غزه الكارثي نحن نتح
نتعامل الان وفق ما هو متوفر لدينا من
امكانيات بدايه شمال قط غزه الان بات بلا
خدمات صحيه على الاطلاق نحاول ان نقوم
بتشغيل جزء من مجمع الشفاء الطبي ولكن هذا
الامر يحتاج الى العديد من الاحتياجات من
خلال المؤسسات الامميه نحن تواصلنا مع
المؤسسات الامميه من اجل توفير الاحتياجات
الطارئه لتشغيل ما يمكن تشغيله في مجمع
الشفاء الطبي وكذلك توفير الوقود اللازم
لتشغيل المولدات الكهربائيه وبالتالي اذا
تم تشغيل مجمع الشفاء الطب فسيكون ذلك
افضل فيما يتعلق بالسكان شمال قطاع غزه
وخاصه ان هناك استهدافات مركزه في شمال
القطاع اضافه الى ان جنوب قطاع غزه الان
لا توجد على الاطلاق يريه في مستشفيات
جنوب قطاع غزه الجرحى الذين يصلون الى
المستشفيات بعد كل مجزره وكل استهداف
يفترشون الارض الطواقم الطبيه تحاول تقديم
خدماتها لحه بامكانيات متواضعه وبسيطه لا
يجد فرصه لدخول كافه الجرحى الى غرف
العمليات وبالتالي الطواقم الطبيه تقوم
بالمفاضلة
وخاصه ان قطاع جنوب قطاع غزه وخاصه منطقه
خانيونس والمنطقه الوسطى تشهد قصف مستمر
وهذا يخلف اعداد كبيره من الجرحى لا
تستطيع معها الطواقم الطبيه التعامل مع
حجم الاصابات ونوعيه الاصابات التي تصل
الى المستشفيات سواء في مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى او مستشفى غزه الاوروبي او ايضا
مجمع ناصر الطبي الذي منذ ساعات الفجر
الاولى ويقوم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا
باستهداف محيطه بشكل مركز من اجل عدم وصول
الطواقم الطبيه اليه وعدم وصول سيارات
الاسعاف اليه وهذا السيناريو هو الذي كان
قد قام به الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل في
مجمع الشفاء الطبي ومستشفى العوده ومستشفى
كمال عدوان وكذلك مستشفى القدس وبالتالي
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الان يمارس نفس
السيناريو ويطبق نفس السناريو الذي انتهجه
في شمال قطاع غزه الى جنوبه وخاصه فيما
يتعلق مجمع ناصر الطبي الواقع الصحي في
جنوب قطاع غزه كارثي غايا لا يوجد مقومات
صحيه منقذه للحياه في جنوب قطاع غزه وهذا
ما يريده الاحتلال الذي يزيد من عملياته
الويه في داخل جنوب قطاع غزه ماذا عن
موضوع نقل الجرحى الى خارج قطاع غزه هل
هناك اي تقدم في هذا السياق للاسف حتى
اللحظه كما قلنا ونجدد هذا القول بان
الاليه المتبعه غير مج وهي تساهم في قتل
المزيد من الذين ينتظرون لاسابيع طويله
قبل ان يتم السماح بخرو الى خارج القطاع
حتى اللحظه النسبه تتراوح في 1% من حجم
الاصابات التي لازالت موجوده في داخل قطاع
غزه هي التي خرجت فقط اقل من 1% وبالتالي
هذه الاليه المتبعه كما قلت تساهم في قتل
المزيد من الجرحى نحن طالبنا جميع الاطراف
طالبنا المؤسسات الامنيه بالضغط على
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للسماح بخروج الجرحى
بشكل مكثف الى خارج القطاع والاولويه
الاولى لدينا 5000 مريض من الحالات
الخطيره والحرجه بحاجه ماسه الى الخروج
خارج قطاع غزه حتى يتم انقاذ حياتهم نحن
يوميا نفقد عشرات الجرحى الذين اصيبوا
خلال الفتره السابقه وينتظرون منذ فتره
طويله للسماح لهم بالخروج الى خارج القطاع
وبالتالي الاليه متبعه هي جزء من السلاح
الذي يستخدمه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في قتل
المزيد من الجرحى شكرا لك دكتور اشرف
القدره المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في قطاع
غزه كنت معنا من رفح